first up we have a very special
unannounced uh performance by one of
your favorites in mind give it up
hello
uh i'm so cold i'm wearing this jacket
and i bought this jacket i'm not a manly
guy and uh
yeah but this jacket wants you to think
i am it's like
you got some dusty logs you want to
throw in the back of a pickup
look at this jacket
i'm ready to help i'll cut you is that
what ben say i
let's [__] ladies i am not
i'm not a manly guy this is me let's
have lemonade that's what i want to say
i want to look like i have chains and i
know how to hook them up to things
this is what i'm thinking is
that's my example i have james and
that's what men are doing they're all
greasy in the chains let's hook them up
to stuff look at that
know where he hook up the chain
all right this jacket will camouflage
that fact
and it does
was that was that is that was that
something did you hear like a ball
because i did
see how easily i scared that this jacket
wants me to be like be cool [__] you
know that's what the jacket is saying to
me and i'm like easy jacket that's
derogatory
i'm made in taiwan
other things a jacket would say you're
too easy that can't entertain you but it
does and we're having a good time
i love when people wear scarves
i'm [__] welcome back i am [__]
mad at you sir i'm not here [__] you
[__]
i'd love to be that like i'm i'm a
friendly butterfly of a man you know
what i mean i'd really like to just come
up on him [__] you you piece of [__]
uh it doesn't even feel right when i'm
joking like i really instantly my
impulse is to apologize to you and i
truly am sorry
you just have to be true to who you are
you know what i'm saying
do you ever see someone yawn when
they're wearing a scarf over their
mouths like this
it looks like they're putting a curse on
you it's very if you're on the subway
and somebody's wearing a scarf
and the jacket's like relax voodoo is
fake
i'm from taiwan i would know that's not
where they do voodoo but
but it's a foreign land that i don't
understand
so i say things there are dragons there
i'll say whatever i want about vietnam
was that even the country i picked
i'm not even listening to me okay
good it's so cold i'm so angry
people are
i'm cold now that's why i'm wearing
manly jacket and uh it's so cold people
are quitting smoking that's how cold it
is people are like really i don't know
about this [__] it's not worth like just
watching your hand like cell phone
conversations too all my cell phone
conversations these days end with uh i
can't feel my fingers
i don't even say goodbyes just like it's
not worth talking to you
this isn't worth it
there are no gloves thick enough to make
it worth discussing this outdoors
why do i have a cell phone let's just go
back to this what does that mean rotary
couldn't think of that word
i went in for it
i went in for it and this came my brain
went do this they'll know
rotary
analog would be a crab would be a clock
that's not digital you call that analog
is it just me or just prohibited sound
like it's allowed prohibited
swimming
doesn't that make you want to go for a
dip it's prohibitive
non-fiction is also confusing don't
interact are you talking about they're
laughing at you is that okay no they
didn't laugh i'm 27 recently i said to
somebody i'm getting really good at my
lefts and rights
i was bragging about my proficiency
i know the word proficiency but i
recently acquired the skill set that i
called lefts and rights and then i saw
someone take what i thought was a left
you see where this is going
and i said he's taking a a left and it
was a right i was wrong
and then i just said i shouldn't be
allowed to drive
i recently heard someone say very
casually speaking of cell phones they
were in uh target which is where i hang
and uh
because that's who
wears this jacket and
this girl is on the phone and she's very
i cannot i don't know how to convey this
to you but she was very serious she was
serious and she went from zero to how
dare you too quickly you know what i
mean she used it you know the expression
how dare it's like how dare you that is
like the king of
bad
you gotta save that how dare you this
girl was on the phone she's like oh
you're not meeting me for lunch
how dare you right
like just something so trivial she just
went right to how dare you you guys that
is what you use when you walk in your
wife is like surrounded by 3 000 men
like guys who really would wear this
jacket they're all having intercourse or
whatever men are trying to do i'm not
sure but my wife's like i'm being
unfaithful and there's just pornographic
things and she looks at me and she's
just like everything i thought was our
love is now gone that's when that's when
you [__] how dare you that's not what
like because then if you're using it for
little things what do you do and that's
it you just have to be like oh shittles
that's all you have
shittle shittles bite size candies and
then turn into a rainbow that's all you
have because you can't say how dare you
because you tipped that bit
how dare you if your hair is in florida
and they're suggesting that you murdered
your wife that you crushed her skull how
dare you that's from the future
you ever just been doing comedy for like
five six minutes and then you quote the
fugitive just because you know it'll
give you pleasure that's the kind of
life i'm living every day [__] you i'm
kidding
oh god so i should wrap it up
how dare you
can i say this i'm speaking of me being
friendly i'm a waiver can i say i'm a
waiver not like you don't sign me when
they're like
atomic wings sign pete
i'm a wavering that i like waving i
really do uh
in new york city you don't get to do it
so much and when i travel i really love
to look for waves you know like because
you wave at somebody here they're like i
think i just joined a gang if you wave
back you're like i'm in the rigmas now
that's the gang zach morris joined if
you watch me
early
we got the red jacket the rigmas like
blue screech off for it
life lesson learned okay that was that
was tj my friend i just invoked him for
a second
and i'm tj miller okay uh so again you
don't wanna and i'm waving and i'm
upstate and i pull up to the corner the
best kind of wave you can get is uh when
you don't wave when you just transmit
with your friendly face this one that
you want to wave you know what it means
i'll pull up and i saw this jogger and i
made this face
and i held it and i
yes i'm looking at you you know what i
mean he's going at a very slow clip and
he saw me and my face was saying wave
guy let's do this and he said hello
neighbor and i said hell yeah
and planets align and norman rockwell's
ghost came up and started sketching us
i'm gonna go pete holmes everybody